donc si vous voulez on est obligé de
remplir un certificat avec le numéro du
lot n'a etc poursuivre les gens cette
racine en vous alors qu'il commençait
déjà s'est massé pas une carte
d'identité c'est rachida il a pas de
validité juridique si vous voulez
simplement la traçabilité qui est
extrêmement importante que vous êtes
vacciné
alors oui on a un petit sertic mais
trois divisions il faut que vous avez ça
il faut que vous arrêtiez avec les
formules
ouais je peux comprendre que peut-être
sa soif de liberté mais bien sûr que si
l'atteinte aux libertés vous mais c'est
comme le confinement
j'étais avec jean paul stahl l'espère
manière japon n'a pas effectivement
utilisé le confinement peut être
atteinte aux libertés bah non c'est une
atteinte aux libertés
c'est pas parce que ces atteintes aux
libertés c'est pas nécessaire c'est pas
ça que je dis je dis qu'il faut d'abord
commencer par le commencement
et dire que oui une atteinte aux
libertés et que wydad autoliberté sont
possibles si elles sont justifiées par
des motifs de santé publique
ici c'est pas le cas et si vous vous
engagez je vous garantie un truc
mettez le toit ça pour le coup pendant
une spécialité en sciences politiques
mettez le doigt dans cet engrenage et
vous allez vous en mordre les doigts
à raison de 15 ans ou de 20 ans ça va
quoi vous parlez que d'atteintes aux
libertés mais si à un moment donné moi
j'oublie l'atteinte à la liberté
si à un moment donné ça nous permet de
pouvoir revenir dans des restaurants
voyager sur evene amour sereinement au
ré ouvrir toute l'économie qui est en
berne en vain la france n'a jamais été
enfin l'europe et le monde le nom md
aussi au bord du précipice depuis
récréation un jour quoi ça vous gêne
d'avoir cette jeune fille vous regardez
regardez n'ya pas longtemps on rentrait
dans les restaurants ont donné son
numéro de téléphone
eh ben c'est qu'on était quoi qu'à
contacter le passé eh ben ça tous les
sens que vous dites c'est bon
autre exemple est parfait qu'est ce qui
s'est passé vous savez ce qui s'est
passé est ce que vous savez pourquoi
cette mesure était stupide adresse
liberté les gens vous savez ce qui s'est
passé les gens ont donné des faux numéro
bien sûr
c'est comme ça on vous avez tort sur un
point je comprends parfaitement ce que
vous dites simplement vous avez tort sur
un point vous partez du principe que
c'est nécessaire qui le décide pourquoi
ce sera nécessaire pourquoi ou est-ce
qu'il est inscrit quelque part que pour
aller bouffer dans un resto je dois
effectivement préfecture la carte et je
vous repose la question le monde
s'attendait à voir la vidéo
on vous avait dit la même chose pour les
masquer on les avait dit mais attention
si vous mettez des masques vous verrez
l'épidémie s'arrêtera finalement
l'épidémie s'est pas arrêtée mais pas
les avis si vous les mettez à
l'extérieur l'épidémie s'arrêtera
finalement s est pas arrêté maintenant
on dit si vous êtes vacciné épidémie
s'arrêtera elle si elle s'arrête pas on
fait quoi
un postulat de départ
et si ça marche pas le bac sans qu'est
ce qu'on fait alors imaginons imagine on
en sait aujourd'hui que ce vaccin ils
empêchent les formes graves
ce qu'on ne sait pas encore c est ce qu
ils empêchent le portage du virus
ils empêchent la transmission s'ils
n'empêchent pas d'une manière très
efficace la transmission à quoi ça sert
autant je vais vous allez allez ça
l'avez vous pouvez vous pouvez vous avez
été vaccinées vous ferez deux journaux
grave mais vous pouvez quelque part le
transport ça c'est ce que je veux dire
mais comment dépendants mais justement
il ya des études qui sont faites là
dessus on va le savoir on va le savoir
quand aimé qu'elle mais madame en a on a
mis un an pour un vaccin canton et
plusieurs années on est en train
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit qu'ils sont
efficaces on s'aperçoit que quand on
vaccine on a quand même une diminution
dans les animations tout cas pour des
pays comme israël ou documents moi je
suis actionnaire on lui en première
ligne les soignants sur normale serait
mon cas j'ai eu et j'ai eu le deux
injections mais je ne sais pas encore
peut-être que je vais avoir un portage
du virus donc on n'a pas tant qu'on n'a
pas cette sécurité
on ne peut pas mais vous aurez des
obligations qui seront dictés par des
pays mais pas mon pays alors aidez pays
qui vous diront vous ne voyez mais vous
dirai pas si vous voulez pas vous faire
accéder vous n'irez pas